what do you do with a couple of inner
tubes two fans and some metal rods well
how about this
it's the kangaroo the ultimate off-road
vehicle
no no Terrenas to job including water I
think the Russian guy with the crazy
two-wheeled vehicle is a genius so we
went to st. Petersburg Russia for a chat
with inventor igor pachenko to find out
why he calls attack the kangaroo nos
Vania King group or shortest oh oh
pushing Paco's Renaud Virginia catarah
Gillette in Australia scheduled to be
witness to his dear Tulsa two-spirit
Ashkenaz before how many wat barraza do
is push Kippur it is associated to the
Sami well that explains how it balances
but how do you steer this awesome hack
he's chosen to use fans for thrust and
with the fans
he has thrust no matter what surface
he's on but not only that the fans give
him the ability to maneuver if he
increases the speed or one fan he can
turn in one direction or increase the
speed on the other fan and turn him the
other direction so as he's driving he
can do exactly what an airplane or a
tank does he can't stop one wheel and
allow the other will to continue to move
and by doing so he can turn marvelous
but how does he go keep his feet right
this vehicle comes alive for me when
he's on the water and the science behind
it is amazing it's all to do with
Archimedes principle Archimedes do tell
us more basically what's happening there
is the wheels need to displace the same
amount of weight and water as the weight
of the vehicle I did a few calculations
he weighs 80 kilos his vehicle weighs 40
kilos together that's 120 kilos and
what's that in water 120 litres so each
tire displays the 60 litres that's like
the volume of a rucksack and that's
nothing it's just such a simple idea
a simple idea that shows good hacking is
science and art the tasty network astre
katana do mesh ah
Bhushan rabbit castelia items to
etiquette that Abood Prada watts snatch
away the prosperity but it's fun